hi I'm Eva Longoria I am going
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me Twitter Eva Longoria
produced John wig one I read wrong you
read correctly I did produce the first
John wick
I saved the movie I really did it was
fun Keanu was amazing and it was an
amazing movie posted way to pedia [ __ ]
has appeared in several advertising
campaigns including People magazine and
people in espanol and I have modeling
contracts with L'Oreal Hanes New York
and helping others never never model
with Hanes I mean isn't that a man's
company what do they make girl stuff
ladies lady Hanes I should hear some
lady I'm not I have been with L'Oreal
for 15 years
next Instagram too funny I wonder do you
know everywhere with that Apple box
I'm very short and so every time I'm
directing I can't see the monitors and
so I usually have to have an Apple box
to even see what the actors are doing
I'm 5 2 posted IMDB godmother Victoria
Beckham and David Beckham daughter
Hartford yes I am I am Harper's God mom
her mom and I have been friends for many
many years
Victoria took myself in campaigns the
Godfather out to dinner and told us we
were gonna be the godparents and we were
so happy you were so excited fun time
fun moment and I loved it I'm the
godmother of her only daughter was a
dancer with the Pussycat Dolls I want
the dance I danced you know the Pussycat
Dolls were a big deal back in the day in
LA and Robin Antin who created a
pussycat dolls would always have guests
dancers every week said Cameron Diaz and
she had christina applegate chat Carmen
Electra I danced we found in their Vegas
opening there's so much fun like I think
back now and I'm like oh my gosh I never
would have done that now just cuz of the
fear like I was fearless back then I was
like I'll do it I'll dance and now I'm
like oh my god I can't do this what I
love most about the girls with the
outfits like
at least EA and the corset and like who
doesn't look good and of course it wakka
moly reminds her phone welcome only
reminds me of a good time that's a walk
Molly does more from Wikipedia it's
actually me Longoria was recognized for
her portrayal of Isabella branya on the
CBS daytime soap opera Young and the
Restless I was I'm young and the
restless' that was like my first big
role and I loved it
wine our baby while in high school
Eva worked in Wendy's part-time for
three years to help earn money for her
quinceanera I did I worked at Wendy's I
was pretty good at it I worked at
Wendy's when I was in high school
because I wanted a quinceanera and my
parents wouldn't don't make eaten yet
so I was like I'm gonna throw myself a
quinceanera I was too young to be
working I was 14 just stole my sister's
ID and we've got a job but then I got
permission to work today about my
parents but I didn't want to tell my
parents I was working huse went to go
work there officially on the net Laura
what's what is Eva Longoria's
relationship like with her sisters
amazing my sisters and I are very very
close and you know I have a
special-needs sister who is my oldest
sister and she's the light of our family
and I tolerate my other two sisters
Emily and Esmeralda I look nothing like
my sisters only that we don't even have
the same illnesses you know when they
get sick they get the same things and I
don't they all think the same and I
don't I still think I'm adopted had I
not done my DNA test that proved I was
my parents daughter and would still
think I'm a doctor was definitely the
black sheep of the family
the only one with black black black
black hair submitted another from
Instagram they know this sent us
something EPA about Daniel where do I
get so much energy from my mom my mom is
the most energetic person I know I
actually always feel like I'm not doing
enough because I remember her doing so
much more going out she would like drive
everybody around and take us to
cheerleading practice and work full-time
and raise a special-needs kid and have
dinner on the table every day at six
o'clock for my dad I don't know how she
did it but I feel like
never doing enough Markham Dora will you
ever recruit her for an HR firm I was
when I moved to Hollywood I went to a
temp agency to get a job and the temp
agency ended up hiring me so I was
recruited that was a headhunter for many
years as a matter fact I was doing so
well as a headhunter I was making more
money as a headhunter then when I've got
my first job on yummy the Restless so I
stayed as a headhunter while I was in
young and restless and I did my work for
my dressing room
at CBS boom Eva after working so long on
one show Desperate Housewives is it
difficult to move on to a completely
different role yes it was so hard it was
a decade of my life playing Gabrielle
Solis and I loved it so much and I
remember I took a lot of time off after
disc drives because I was just tired we
were so exhausted and the first time I
went back to acting was on Brooklyn
nine-nine and I just did a guest star
and I felt like I forgot how to act and
I remember talking to Andy I was like I
don't things aren't coming out of my
mouth
I was so rusty it was just being in a
different character skin and I was like
I don't know how to play this character
because I had been Gabrielle Solis for
so long I miss it I miss her
submit